foreign
clear every Major Medical Association
agrees that gender affirming health care
for transgender kids is a best practice
and potentially life-saving all of this
begs an important question what are
these policies actually trying to solve
for LGBT Qi plus people can't be erased
or forced back into any closets and kids
across our nation should be allowed to
be who they are without the threat that
their parents or their doctor could be
imprisoned simply for helping them and
loving them uh President Biden has
committed in both words and actions to
fight for all Americans and will not
hesitate to hold these states
accountable
I would also note since I've had a
rotation of fabulous colleagues in here
today today we have Adan Patel here you
may all know him any of you who work on
immigration and climate issues know him
very well I often joke with him that we
gave him the easy assignments we did not
it's just because he's super talented uh
vidon I'll say about him he's a
beautiful writer he's a fast writer I
don't know if that means he could be a
wire reporter I think he has a very
promising career in government ahead of
him but just wanted to highlight vadan
and his amazing contributions and
everything he does to help me help all
of us help the president every day with
that
terrific I've got uh got three things
thanks so much
um Ukraine's foreign minister at neither
they made it very clear that uh this
country needs more weapons and needs
them fast I'm wondering if it's time for
the U.S and other allies to not just
provide defensive Weaponry but actually
provide an offensive government well uh
let me give you a sense of where we are
um as of now we have provided uh
committed to providing 1.7 billion
dollars of uh weapons of security
assistance uh to Ukraine since the
beginning of this conflict more than 2
billion since the president took office
there are transfers of sim of systems at
nearly every single day I would note we
just announced two days ago uh 100
million dollars in javelins which are a
critical weapon that the ukrainians have
been using effectively to fight the
Russians push back the Russians and
defend their country I would also note
um that as a as um
as a as it relates to the type of
systems and material we are providing
for every Russian tank in Ukraine the
United States will have or has provided
10 anti-tanks systems if you factor in
contributions from allies we're almost
at 90 to one that means one tank Russian
tank 10 anti-tank systems to fight them
back for every Russian armored vehicle
in Ukraine the United States will have
provided about three anti-armor systems
if you factor in contributions from
allies it's about 25 to 1. the way this
works and the last thing I'm saying
that's your next question the way that
it works is that uh the Ukrainian
leaders uh request a range of assistance
they often provide us lists we go
through that list we determine what we
can provide we provide a vast vast
majority of what they're requesting if
we don't have access to it sometimes
it's russian-made military equipment we
work with our allies and partners to see
what they can provide and our Focus as
our as Department of Defense officials
have conveyed on the hill when they've
testified this week has been providing
providing what they're trained on and
what we know is effective in fighting
this war and we've already seen to date
that the use of the security assistance
has been Central and essential in in
effectively fighting the war as they
have done
uh go ahead I'm saying that that's
sufficient that you feel that you've
given them enough I mean what do you
mean by those metrics well I met I
provided them because I think it's
interesting or compelling to understand
right the range and the significance of
and the totality of the type of
assistance we've provided we have not
stopped nor are we stopping providing
additional security assistance we have
announcements nearly every couple of
days I just think that to me was
interesting and compelling to better
understand the significance and the
broad scope of those assistance but
you're saying there'll be no let up in
your efforts no I don't think I conveyed
that in any in any way
we're looking at other systems some of
them larger more sophisticated that may
be useful going forward are you talking
about the systems that allies might have
and we're trying to backfill it what was
for clarity's perspective was he trying
to say that well partly yes because
there are systems of course we have
access to we have the best military in
the world we have a range of systems we
have access to that we have been
providing we will continue to provide
there are certain systems as you noted
the S 300 is one of them of course uh
where they have requested we have
continued to work with allies and
partners on what systems and uh uh and
Equipment they have access to and they
would have the capacity to provide
sometimes that means backfilling systems
and there is also assist uh systems and
weapon systems that they may request
that we may not talk about because for
operational reasons uh and their own
um uh process it wouldn't be to their
benefit to do that
potentially talking about U.S systems
that we just aren't necessarily aware of
at this point he's he's talking about
we're not going to detail always every
type of system or every type of weapon
we're going to work with allies to
provide or provide we have provi we have
detailed it quite extensively from here
but we're not going to detail everything
we haven't over the course of time for
operational purposes but what he was
conveying is that we'll continue to work
with our partners and allies in uh
meeting the needs and the requests that
the ukrainians uh have put forward and
then uh Germany's foreign intelligence
Service uh briefed the Parliamentary
committee over there that intercepted
radio communications of Russian soldiers
talking about killing civilians zero is
either aware of that intelligence or
does it have any intercepts of its own
but but sure something similar I have
seen the reports but I don't have
anything more on those reports or the
intelligence yes um I guess the
president obviously tested negative
today and according to CDC guidance
yesterday I'm sorry yesterday and
speaker Pelosi was not considered a
close contact but it seems like a very
close call I know you said that he had a
second booster and that he's following
CDC guidelines but given the importance
of his role and his age is the White
House considering any stricter measures
to keep him safe more mass wearing fewer
big venue events more outdoor events
well when you say it's a close call I'm
not sure what you mean by that
they were in two events at the White
House together within two days she
tested positive sure sure okay well for
clarity purposes what the way a close
contact is defined it's not arbitrary
it's not something made up by the White
House it's CDC guidelines and how they
Define it as being within six feet for a
cumulative total of 15 minutes over 24
hour period that they were not all of
their interactions were publicly
available I think you saw them and
that's how that assessment is made in
terms of additional testing or anything
along those lines uh that those
assessments would be made by the
president's doctor he was tested last
evening and tested negative we have
incredibly stringent protocols here at
the White House that we keep in place to
keep the president safe to keep
everybody safe those go over and above
CDC guidelines and that includes
ensuring that anyone who is going to be
around the president
um is tested every member of the staff
is on a regular test protocol if you're
going to see him in person whether
you're traveling with him or you're
meeting the Oval Office you will be
tested if you we we try to do socially
distance meetings when necessary for
those employees who test positive they
are required to isolate of course an
alignment with CDC guidance must test
negative before returning to work that
is also a step that goes over and above
but we we are going to continue to
follow the protocols and I would remind
you and reiterate that we also put out a
plan just a month ago that made clear
that well covid-19 will continue to be
with us and we will see cases rise and
fall as we are seeing them rise now to
be expected given the transmissibility
of ba2 we can now we now have steps to
uh to go back to many of our normal
routines in align in alignment with what
the CDC continues to recommend given the
fact that there has been this upcoming
among you know people who have been
following CDC guidelines are there plans
to revisit those guidelines or edit them
in some way and given the uptick that
would be up to the CDC but again I think
when they put out these guidelines they
made clear that it was about looking at
data on hospitalizations and even deaths
and what we have a plan to address and I
would note I I have it with me because
we really like coveted props this week
right here we have copies for anyone who
would like a copy and this is a hundred
page preparedness plan that we put out
that uh meant to protect against and
treat covid prepare for new variants
prevent shutdowns vaccinate the world we
expected there to be
um ups and downs and increases and with
a transmissible a variant that's as
transmissible as ba2 that's what we're
seeing at this point in time in the
white house uh in among the Press Corps
among the general public and the most
important message we're sending to the
public is is that we have steps in place
that we can take to continue to address
it and even as we're continuing to fight
uh kovid we can uh for the most part
return to our normal routines yeah
Congress voted to remove the most
favorite Nation trade status for Russia
and Belarus and ban oil imports does
president 100 to zero right yes uh yes
this is something the president uh
supports has called for and certainly
plans to sign it back on Covenant you
just said that anyone who's around the
president is tested does that apply just
to Executive Office employees or is that
true also of any members of Congress or
invited guests who are here there are
individuals who have a meeting with the
president that's what I was referring to
our own protocols now if you're at an
event obviously there are assessments
made on a case-by-case but if somebody
is going to be in close proximity
standing next to him sitting next to him
on a stage that would be obviously
different than a broad group of
attendees and Givens or the uptick in
cases that we've seen here at the White
House on the hill there seems to be you
know cases going around in the political
world here in Washington and the fact
that sometimes you do go beyond the CDC
recommended guidelines is there any plan
just to test the president daily for the
next few days or a week or so that would
be a decision made by his doctor but
that is not deemed to be necessary at
this point
the first lady's detail was placed on
administrative leave after they
associated with it and were provided
gifts from two men who are pretending to
be Homeland Security investigations
agents is the first lady aware of is the
president aware of this how concerned
are that I don't have any comment from
here I'd point you to uh the Secret
Service and others investigating just do
you have any further guidance on what
these two men were after or who they may
have been working with being
investigated and I would point you to
the proper agencies for any further
comment go ahead thanks Chad I'm back on
covet it's pretty clear that vaccines
and boosters are not going to prevent
you from getting pooped but we know from
science that masking
given you yourself saying you know how
transmissible ba2 is are there any
conversations Happening Here on campus
at the White House to reinstate a mask
mandate we would continue to follow CDC
guidance that's not what they're
recommending given we are in a yellow
zone at this point in time there are
individuals who are masked because they
are close contact and that is part of
our protocols they have had a close
contact and that's part of our protocols
and individuals who may decide to mask
because they have health issues in their
family personally and that's something
we also certainly support but we would
always abide by CDC guidance and go
beyond it if necessary given what you've
said about the plan in place and about
living with covid
um is the end goal not just
spread anymore
again
trying to stop this red of course we're
trying to stop the spread and we have
the means to address that we're also
though I would point you to the 100 page
plan we put out just a month ago where
it made clear that we will continue to
see covered covid will continue to be
with us we will see cases rise and fall
we now know how to protect ourselves
from hospitalization and death which is
hugely important we know how
um how much of getting vaccinated
getting boosted can protect you and we
know here in the White House of course
99 of people are vaccinated many many
people are boosted and so we have
policies that that also go even beyond
what is most important right now is
we're looking broadly to the country is
the fact that we are very concerned
about the failure of Congress to
continue to fund our coveted response
the fact that we have needed to
therefore end our program for the
uninsured we are not going to be able to
make purchases of a broad scope of
boosters of of
um of Eva shell to it which is a
treatment for immunocompromise or
preventative treatment for
immunocompromised that when we get to
the end of June our testing capacity
will be at risk of collapsing and as
we're looking broadly beyond the White
House of how we're planning that as our
greatest biggest concern at this point
in time
sure you just talked about how his
no reporters were allowed in the room no
TV cameras were allowed in the room to
help record that history can you help us
understand that decision well today was
meant to be a private moment between the
president and judge Jackson and we made
a decision late in the process that we
would have some photographers some of
your colleagues in the news media in the
room to capture it for history those
photos have been used by networks
including likely your network over the
course of the last hour but this was
meant to be a private moment tomorrow as
we've announced we have an event a
moment in history where uh certainly the
president will be speaking we will have
a range of guests it will be an outside
event and we'll be marking it in that
way go ahead Thanks Jen how can you guys
say that President Biden was not a
contact with speaker Pelosi when there
is video of the speaker kissing him well
Peter the way that it is defined is by
the Center for Disease Control the CDC
and their definition of it is 15 minutes
of contact within a set period of time
and within six feet uh it did not meet
that bar it does not mean that uh that
no one will get coveted around the world
who does not have a close contact it
just means we are defining for all of
you uh whether the president and their
interaction met the definition of the
CDC of a close contact half the cabinet
was there on Tuesday at least two
additional cabinet members Fernando and
Garland already have coven is there a
threat that this is going to be a
national security problem if the cabinet
comes to the White House and starts
getting infected with Kobe well I don't
think Peter we can assess where they
where they got covered or where where
they where they acquired covet or
whatever the right way to say that is I
don't know that it was Tuesday there are
other events obviously that have
happened over the course of the last
week as well uh they are all boosted uh
they are all many of them are able to
work from home as many uh staff and even
reporters are who are who are vaccinated
and boosted uh and they all have a
talented and experienced team who is
stepping into their shoes where needed
in the office when the last president
wanted to host a big event for a supreme
court nominee here at the White House
some folks got coveted and then former
Vice President Biden called it a super
spreader event so is there any risk that
this event tomorrow for a Biden Supreme
Court now Justice is going to be a super
spreader event well one at that point in
time vaccines weren't available people
were not vaccinated it certainly puts us
in a different space this event is also
going to be outside tomorrow uh and then
on a different topic when title 42
expires next month what is the plan for
the 18 000 migrants a day that are going
to cross do you want them to get jobs
here is there something else that you
want these 18 000 a day to be doing I
don't know where you're basing your
specific numbers on Peter but what I
would tell you
I've got it right here earlier this week
the department gave reporters and
estimated up to 18 000 migrants could be
apprehended at the border each day if
title 42 were working up up two and
we'll see what happens and obviously
we're taking steps to convey that this
is not the time to come uh individuals
who come to the Border this is what
would happen CBP and Ice would work
together to ensure that anyone who
enters the country without authorization
is put into immigration proceedings as
quickly as possible CBP has been working
with ice to ensure individuals awaiting
processing in the interior of the
country monitor under would be monitored
under the alternatives to detention
program we know that to date nearly 80
percent of non-citizens waiting in the
interior under prosecutor prosecutorial
discretion have either received a notice
to appear or are still within their
window to report that is what would
happen in addition I would note the
Department of Homeland Security also put
together a preparedness plan to continue
addressing irregular migration that
involves surging personnel and resources
to the board or improving border
processing implementing mitigation
measures and working with other
countries in the hemisphere to manage
migration those are all steps that
they're working to do in order to
implement when we get to that point in
time the last one on this now that the
Texas governor is saying that he's going
to start busting border crossers to
Washington DC when they get here are you
guys going to help them find a place to
stay and something for them to do well
I'm not aware of what Authority the
governor would be doing that under I
think it's pretty clear this is a
publicity stunt his own uh office admits
that a migrant would need to voluntarily
be transported and they can't compel
them to because again enforcement of our
country's immigration laws lies with the
federal government not a state
Washington D.C well listen I don't know
but I know that the governor of Texas or
any state does not have the legal
authority to compel anyone to get on a
bus go ahead is there pressure to avoid
saying the President Biden has had a
close contact given his position and the
demands of his schedule no we announced
yesterday the vice president had a close
contact and if there is 15 minutes that
he spends with somebody in person within
six feet and they test positive for
covid then that would be a close contact
you 17 minutes to get covid right so it
could take less than that obviously he
was around Nancy Pelosi and many others
are you doing anything differently is
there anything being done differently
given that circumstance for the
president he was tested last night and
tested negative and if his doctor deems
you should be tested more frequently he
certainly could do that but again the
CDC guidelines are in place and the CDC
um uh specifics on what a close contact
and how it's defined or in place for a
reason to give everybody clear
data-driven guidance it is clear but
it's not always accurate right because
it doesn't take 15 minutes to get
covered and this is more transmissible
this latest variant and other variants
in the past it doesn't necessarily
require that much time for example
yesterday we were in the state dining
room the president was face to face with
many individuals right up in their mugs
for extended periods of time because he
was enjoying this moment a chance to
visit with folks so for clarity not
everybody in that room was tested in
advance of arriving correct correct so
some of those people who may have been
further back but ultimately had I don't
know five minutes we watched for an hour
literally in the room maybe not have
been with him for 15 minutes but could
have been in his face having not been
tested well again if individuals are
within uh six feet of him for 15 minutes
or more that's considered a close
contact no one in there was
that I'm tested negative before her
visit today I trust I don't have any
more details on contagi Brown's
Jackson's testing protocols let me ask
you about the Secret Service uh very
quickly if I can does the president
maintain confidence in the director of
The Secret Service James Murray yes
is it your sense that uh just judge
Jackson will Ascend to the bench sooner
than the end of the term because our
understanding was that Justice Breyer
was going to retire at the end of the
term I don't have any updates on that
but or any changes to that no
I want to give you a chance to respond
uh Jonathan Swan did an interview with
Mitch McConnell this morning in which he
spawn asked McConnell whether if the
Republican should take the Senate in the
midterm elections and another vacancy
should occur while this President is
still in office whether a
republican-controlled senate would hold
a hearing on another Biden nominee he
refused to answer that question do you
have a response to that what do you
think it says about the health of our
constitutional system well I think given
it's a day where uh with bipartisan
support we have a new uh we are about to
have a new member of the Supreme Court a
historic and eminently qualified member
of the Supreme Court and she did get
three uh Republicans supporting her that
is that is a good sign and something we
should take a moment to celebrate uh
certainly we don't anticipate or predict
I have no prediction of an additional
opening but we would certainly expect
and call for all members of the Senate
to to operate as professionally as the
president and our team did in this case
which is ensuring that there was advice
and consent that she met that the our
nominee met with 97 Senators that's
obviously great a great number from the
other party that is how we would conduct
ourselves and we would expect the uh the
same in response
is CDC aside and distance and et cetera
has the president expressed any a
surprise or the amazement that there's a
number of cases around him and is he is
he asked for people to stay away what's
it just this kind of human level
response to what's going on no
no
no
not blessed by the fact that a growing
number of people around him or getting
covered we have anticipated that there
would be rising numbers of coveted cases
it is not the numbers in here where
where it was around Omicron and I don't
know if it was among the Press Court
certainly wasn't among the general
public uh he knows there are a number of
steps and precautions that we put in
place and we take to protect him and
protect the vice president and other
senior members of the team that includes
testing uh that for anybody who goes to
see him that includes uh social
distancing in meetings whenever possible
a step we take an additional
precautionary step we take uh in order
to protect him and protect other senior
members of the White House
is there any ongoing or a future near
future conversations with China on the
Russia situation or is the U.S just
concluded uh China's not going to budge
on this position which is do not really
get involved and try to push them all
there will be ongoing conversations with
China I would expect including our
expectation that they abide by sanctions
and that they not provide material
support to Russia I don't have anything
to predict in terms of which channel it
will happen through uh next but
certainly I would expect there will be
ongoing continued conversations
given his health profile s to be
expected not to be a serious case if you
were to get it well I think that is what
we see statistically
um and through as we look at Health
analysis and data but obviously uh you
know we would he would be treated by his
doctor and I'm not going to make a
prediction of that at this point in time
it's not fair for us to conclude that
the event tomorrow what the factor in it
being outside and being tomorrow given
outside the training today supposed to
be a beautiful day that is a big factor
it was part of part of some deciding how
to have this company
I would tell you that the biggest
factors are actually that and we would
have had events outside earlier in the
week too had the weather allowed um it
is that time of year and certainly we do
know that it is better to have events
outside when you can have them outside
it is meant to be it is supposed to be a
beautiful day I'm not a weather person
but that is what everything is telling
us um and also we want to be able to
invite a large number of people and uh
this would enable us to do that so those
are the biggest factors but there's no
question Josh that that also is true uh
statistically is actually a little less
clear than the link between the two
closets that you're linking they talk
about what's this person less than six
feet away from someone yes
and they ask they say to consider the
time spent with someone starting two
days before so that includes both the
ACA event and yesterday's event so and
then separately they say have been in
the presence of someone with confirmed
or suspected code for accumulative total
over 15 minutes or more of a 24-hour
period
as far as we know that people are
closing by the left right after the
event there was a 14 minutes yesterday
and they spent about 45 minutes
she wasn't
seven feet away from the speaker Pelosi
is now in close contact with 15 minutes
six feet away would have been a close
contact
in a way of saying wizard with a
discussion of whether to treat him as
close contact
well he is tested regularly as you know
he was tested yesterday he will be
tested again soon he's attested
typically a couple of times a week if he
is a if he were a close contact the only
difference or I don't even know that it
would be a difference would be a five
day a test five days after your contact
so
days in public okay and if and if he is
at close contact that is what exactly he
will do
what are the short-term consequences of
having new funding in places there is
previously announced funding namely
advisors philippeclobin and when do you
think the statements of the monoformal
antibodies will run out they were
supposed to run MMA if you've been
shipping tourism how long will it covers
I may have to check on that specific
component for you Josh and I'm happy to
do that I mean what we do know is that
by the end of June the testing capacity
will be at risk our testing capacity
will be at the risk at risk of
collapsing at least from the federal
government and what we can provide uh we
know that we can't buy any additional
treatments Beyond those that have
already been paid for and contracted of
course including preventative treatments
for immunocompromised those treatments
as you know take uh often take six
months to manufacture so we'd also be
losing out on Supply that we intended to
purchase for September through January
and of course the uninsured fund is
already closed but I can certainly check
on the next purchase of monoclonal uh
and and if if we have
um any ability to purchase that the bill
passes three weeks from now versus
having passed this week well we would be
able to have the funding hopefully to uh
reopen some of our uninsured uh
programming we'd be able to get ahead
and plan ahead for purchases of uh of
testing to ensure we had testing
capacity to make sure we could uh could
place some orders for treatment
preventative treatments for the
immunocompromise that just delays the
the process and as we know they're going
on a two-week recess right now
thanks I appreciate it I have a
non-public question but you can ask me a
covered question too go ahead thanks I
appreciate it um I just wanted to
specific about tomorrow are folks who
are attending going to be required to
take any additional steps you know other
than it being outside and all that stuff
but the testing by Senators for example
or you know distance kept by the
president is there going to be anything
above and beyond just being outside not
that I'm aware of but it being outside
is certainly an important component here
um and uh typically uh individuals who
are going to be in close proximity like
on the stage or something they would be
tested but there are protocols that are
evaluated in a case-by-case as we have
events and a question on Puerto Rico
okay right there's a million people Plus
without power there a lot of people
criticizing that the federal government
has not done enough to fix the grid
there after recent hurricanes I wonder
what you know is the president running
on this are there any actions uh that
the president is planning to do there
sure let me check I know we've provided
a broad range and a significant amount
of financial assistance but let me let
me check and see what the status is at
this point in time can I also ask you
about the Amir lock uh the case
involving a Miralax for the officers
that uh are you know not charged in that
case is the president running on that
and is there any any does he have any
thoughts on like the no not warrants I
think you you addressed this in February
a little bit but I wonder if there's
been any action or movement or further
conversation about it well um
let me give you I mean so first like so
many Across the Nation and obviously
this news is a reminder of uh how we've
all mourned the tragic death of mirlock
and our thoughts and prayers continue to
be with his family uh president uh is
committed of course he is aware of
um um and I would point you to the
Department of Justice for any specifics
about next legal actions but uh the
president is committed to ensuring fair
and partial and effective policing
keeping our communities safe those goals
go hand in hand and we can achieve them
in part by building trust between the
police and communities they serve so to
go to your other questions in September
the Attorney General issued a new policy
imposing restrictions on the use of no
knock warrants chokeholds and
restraints by federal agents uh
President Biden also continues to call
on uh on Congress to pass comprehensive
police reform legislation but since
Republicans refuse to support the George
Floyd Justice and policing actors admit
we are looking at additional steps we
can take We are continuing to look at
them on Executive action to advance
police reform obviously something we put
a pause on well that was being
negotiated I don't have an update on the
timing of that but that is something we
are continuing to look at to a build on
of course the actions taken by the
Department of Justice
that vice president Pamela Harris is
considered a close contact
UM CTC guidance that's who were arrested
today she was presiding over the vote
for
um
Jackson and didn't wear a mask I guess
is the White House ever have a response
to that was that a preacher protocol or
I guess what made it different that she
didn't have to wear a mask I haven't
seen I obviously watched most parts of
the vote but I know that she was alone
up kind of on the dice for the vast
majority of that
um and of course she has been wearing a
mask otherwise um but beyond that I
haven't I haven't done any further
analysis and then one more question
um sort of on immigration sure um there
are reports that there is an increased
number of Ukrainian refugees heading to
this that are at the southern border
around 2000 in Tijuana I guess that was
my wondering what are the
administration's plans to kind of
address a rise of Ukrainian refugees
that might come to the southern border
you know the state department hasn't
really outlined the specifics on how
they want to you know address allowing a
hundred thousand Ukrainian refugees to
the U.S I guess is there any other
preparations that are being made in
addition to whatever expected rise of
migrants coming to the Border
um once title 42 ends sure well I would
say that we are still working through
the policy process but hopefully we'll
have more to say on soon about what
specific mechanisms ukrainians can apply
who wish to come to the United States
even though we know the vast majority uh
have made clear they would like to stay
in neighboring countries which is why
we're providing the most humanitarian
assistance of any country in the world
to support those efforts that
neighboring countries are have
undertaken to host refugees there are
very good questions I'm sure you have
about family reunification
prioritization and whether there would
be prioritization for individuals who
fear persecution and things along those
lines those are all important questions
that are being discussed um you know we
are still implementing title 42 at the
border for anyone who comes uh to the
border and we're working toward
implementation uh of the lifting of
title 42 uh next month and and we would
apply the policy to everybody but
obviously uh coming from any country but
obviously there would be these programs
and we'd have more details before then
for sure uh that uh ukrainians who are
eligible would be able to apply for okay
but thank you John I have two questions
the first one is the budget day in
Ottawa today and uh up to eight uh
billion dollar in new money will go to
defense uh purpose which will bring
bring Canada's uh defense uh
contribution to approximately 1.5
percent of the GDP
not yet to the two percent uh those
Administration wish Canada would do more
considering the actual War
well we applaud that increase and we
applaud Canada's efforts and support for
us in standing up against the invasion
of of Ukraine by President Putin and the
Russians and they are an important
partner and continue to be and my second
question it goes back to
um the aid the um uh Adu detailed at the
beginning of the briefing to the uh
Russian military all sorts of Ukrainian
military yeah Ukraine military of course
sorry
um I just want to um verify again uh you
you refer to you know there are requests
coming to you and you go through the
list and sometimes you need uh old
Soviet uh equipment
um are the mig-29s and still in the list
and is the administration considering uh
transferring those uh polish planes to
you our policy has not changed but other
countries of course could make that
determination and decide to do and we
certainly wouldn't stand in the way but
our policy has not changed when uh so
when President Biden uh continued the
pause on student loan uh payments refame
as he said
um that that pause will provide
continued Lifeline as we recover and
rebuild from the pandemic you said today
you want to stop the spread of covid so
my question is if still recovering from
the pandemic why then is title 42 going
to be relifted as a revision a revisit
that you can look at that and have we
just recovered from the border then does
that
does that let me see if I can unpack a
few things in there
um first on on the announcement about
the extension of student loan uh pot the
student loan pause what I said yesterday
is also that what we look at is the
impact of the pandemic on the economic
recovery and even though the economy has
is very strong look at the UI data from
today look at the jobs data from last
Friday we certainly know that costs are
continuing to impact people across the
country including students who have who
have or former students who have student
loan payments they need to make and the
president's going to look for every way
he can lower costs for the American
people whether that is the family fix
that he announced with former president
Obama earlier this week or the
announcement about the pause on student
loan payments the decision about title
42 is a decision made by the CDC a
public health decision it's on
immigration Authority or policy it's a
public health decision and we respect
the authority given to them by Congress
to make that determination the president
said that uh sanctions were not a
deterrent on Russia going into Ukraine
um yesterday treasury secretary Janet
Yellen is saying that the U.S would use
all its sanctioned tools should China
move towards Taiwan so is that message a
deterrent or not well we have sanctioned
China in the past as you know for human
rights abuses and we have sanctioned a
range of countries uh certainly around
the world I would say sanctions have a
range of purposes including putting
consequences in place and where we are
as it relates to the war in Ukraine is
also making that much more difficult for
President Putin to fund this war and
that is a huge priority to us I don't
have any predictions about future
sanctions I would leave that at the
comments of this treasury secretary
given how intertwined our economies are
could we really do sanctions on China
like we are that is an assessment that
the Department of Treasury would have to
make but I don't have a prediction
beyond what the Secretary of Treasury
said go ahead uh yeah this week you've
been critical Republicans trying to add
amendment votes onto the covered funding
bill
um specifically regarding title 42.
yesterday you said they decided to move
the goal posts and that the White House
is questioning whether Republicans are
acting in good faith or if they're just
plain politics but if Democratic
senators Mark Kelly Kristen Cinema Joe
manchin Maggie Assan and John tester
joining Republicans in this effort does
the White House have the same criticism
we've heard about Republicans does that
apply to these Democratic senators as
well look regardless of who's standing
against this our larger Point here is if
we do not have treatments vaccines or
tests that the American people need
Americans will die from covid and
whether they support or oppose the
administration on immigration or child
care or environment environmental rules
anybody and so our point is not
political the vast majority of people
who are opposing this moving forward are
Republicans that is a fact but our our
Point here is that there is an urgency
to move forward we can have a range of
debates about a range of issues we have
disagreements on that's fine immigration
Child Care environmental rules we
welcome that by the way the president
put forward an immigration bill is first
day in office if Republicans want to
work on immigration come on down to the
White House we're happy to work with you
on it but right now this is a game of
politics and we need to get this funding
otherwise people in the country are
going to die that's our larger point and
a quick follow-up on
on vice president Harris if she was a
close contact tomorrow during the event
or if there's any reception behind the
scenes what should be required to wear a
mask indoors She'll follow CDC protocols
in any other events go ahead um yeah the
um Congressional portal from from the
confirmation vote today uh tells us that
Senator Rand Paul cast his vote from the
GOP Cloud crew he was in casual clothes
without a suit jacket or tie so unable
to come onto the floor the reports I
think two other Republican Senators may
have gone similar is that an appropriate
way to to vote on a historic location
like this I will tell you I'm not
spending a lot of time nor is the
president thinking about the dress code
of Rand Paul today we're thinking about
the historic confirmation of an
eminently qualified black woman to serve
on the Supreme Court not really worried
about his khakis if I may as well we've
enjoyed your shout outs to members of
your team I wonder if this means you're
now working your notice
I'm sorry what whether you're now is
that an American phrase whether you're
now working yeah I think I don't know
that it's an American phrase um I I have
I I am no no I I love the britishness
and the accent not to put you on on
notice of sort
um look I I think it is simply a
reflection of uh my appreciation for the
incredible people on my team uh that I
get to work with every day
um I've shadowed them out in the past
before I've made I've I've presented
them with sashes to wear all sorts of
embarrassing things and uh I think
working in the White House just like
being a reporter people think you have
glamorous glamorous setups back there
I'm here to confirm that is not the case
but
um our team Works their tails off
there's a lot going on and it's just
simply an effort to recognize that I
have nothing to announce about questions
yeah yes what is this Administration
response to Israel for their role as
mediator in this Russia Ukraine crisis
and I have a follow-up question okay uh
well we certainly support the efforts of
a range of leaders to that uh who are
hoping to play a diplomatic role here
and there are a number of leaders around
the world who have also had engagements
with Russians and engagements with the
ukrainians and we just ask that they all
engage closely with ukrainians as well
okay to help Europe develop energy
independence from Russia with a by
Administration drop its opposition to
the EU East Smith pipeline being
developed by Israel Cyprus and Greece
look I think there's going to be
decisions made by European leaders about
how to reduce their uh their any any
level of dependence they have on Russian
oil you've seen a number of leaders this
week announce their intention to ban oil
imports from Russia but I would remind
you that pipelines are a means of moving
oil it's not a means of production but I
didn't point you to the European leader
to speak to that thank so much everyone
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
a little bit
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yeah yeah
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
tonight
yes
you know
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
aggression against its smaller neighbor
cannot and should not sit in the Human
Rights Council
not after what we have seen on pictures
from butcher European
mariopol and some other places of
massacres in Ukraine
suspension from the Human Rights Council
is only an urgent temporary measure
after independent human rights and
criminal investigations further legal
action has to be taken against
perpetrators of the atrocity crimes
unfortunately the rules of procedure do
not allow us to suspend Russian
federation's permanent membership in the
security Council and its veto right
although they are in the current
situation also equally inappropriate and
counterproductive for the protection of
International Peace and security as well
as for the prevention of atrocity crimes
against the population of Ukraine
if we cannot do more to protect innocent
victims through the security Council we
are at least no longer offending them by
allowing the Russian Federation to sit
in the Human Rights Council
we owe this reluctant decision on
suspending the rights of membership of
the Russian Federation in the Human
Rights Council to all victims of the
aggression against Ukraine
and this nomination is confirmed history
was made today
the Senate confirming Judge katanji
Brown Jackson to the Supreme Court on a
bipartisan basis fulfilling President
Biden's promise on the campaign Trail to
nominate the first black woman to the
nation's highest court President Biden
and judge Jackson watching the vote
count from the Roosevelt room vice
president Kamala Harris presiding over
judge Jackson's confirmation vote in the
Senate judge Jackson held one-on-one
meetings with 97 Senators on the hill
she also sat through over 20 hours of
questioning during her hearings and
filed 330 pages of written responses
that's more written questions than any
previous Supreme Court nominee all
Democrats rallied behind judge Jackson
along with three Republicans Joe Jackson
will go down in history as an American
Giant upon whose shoulders others will
stand tall Republicans tried to paint
her as soft on crime Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell once again
slamming Jackson shortly before the vote
claiming she's failing to commit to
oppose expanding the Supreme Court the
solution
is for all the justices
to stay in their Lane there's one right
number of justices who seek to follow
the law
the number is nine ABC news now learning
just Jackson promised Republican senator
Susan Collins that she would never take
a position on that issue once judge
Jackson joins the court this fall she'll
be taking on several controversial cases
encompassing the death penalty the Clean
Water Act and the Humane treatment of
animals in our food supply to name a few
now one of the biggest cases of the Fall
so far is the challenge to Harvard and
the University of North Carolina's use
of race and college admissions a case
that could determine the future of
affirmative action Nationwide judge
Jackson says she'll recuse herself from
that case given her position on the
Harvard's Board of overseers ikejachi
ABC News Washington
and this nomination is confirmed history
was made today
the Senate confirming just katanji Brown
Jackson to the Supreme Court on a
bipartisan basis fulfilling President
Biden's promise on the campaign Trail to
nominate the first black woman to the
nation's highest court President Biden
and judge Jackson watching the vote
count from the Roosevelt room vice
president Kamala Harris presiding over
judge Jackson's confirmation vote in the
Senate judge Jackson held one-on-one
meetings with 97 Senators on the hill
she also sat through over 20 hours of
questioning during her hearings and
filed 330 pages of written responses
that's more written questions than any
previous Supreme Court nominee all
Democrats rallied behind judge Jackson
along with three Republicans Joe Jackson
will go down in history as an American
Giant upon whose shoulders others will
stand tall Republicans tried to paint
her as soft on crime Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell once again
slamming Jackson shortly before the vote
claiming she's failing to commit to
oppose expanding the Supreme Court the
solution
is for all the justices
to stay in their Lane there's one right
number of justices who seek to follow
the law
the number is nine ABC news now learning
just Jackson promised Republican senator
Susan Collins that she would never take
a position on that issue once judge
Jackson joins the court this fall she'll
be taking on several controversial cases
encompassing the death penalty the Clean
Water Act and the Humane treatment of
animals in our food supply to name a few
now one of the biggest cases of the Fall
so far is the challenge to Harvard and
the University of North Carolina's use
of race and college admissions a case
that could determine the future of
affirmative action Nationwide judge
Jackson says she'll recuse herself from
that case given her position on the
Harvard's Board of overseers ikejachi
ABC News Washington
and this nomination is confirmed history
was made today
the Senate confirming just katanji Brown
Jackson to the Supreme Court on a
bipartisan basis fulfilling President
Biden's promise on the campaign Trail to
nominate the first black woman to the
nation's highest court President Biden
and judge Jackson watching the vote
count from the Roosevelt room vice
president Kamala Harris presiding over
judge Jackson's confirmation vote in the
Senate judge Jackson held one-on-one
meetings with 97 Senators on the hill
she also sat through over 20 hours of
questioning during her hearings and
filed 330 pages of written responses
that's more written questions than any
previous Supreme Court nominee all
Democrats rallied behind judge Jackson
along with three Republicans Joe Jackson
will go down in history as an American
Giant upon whose shoulders others will
stand tall Republicans tried to paint
her as soft on crime Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell once again
slamming Jackson shortly before the vote
claiming she's failing to commit to
oppose expanding the Supreme Court the
solution
is for all the justices
to stay in their Lane there's one right
number of justices who seek to follow
the law
the number is nine ABC news now learning
just Jackson promised Republican senator
Susan Collins that she would never take
a position on that issue once judge
Jackson joins the court this fall she'll
be taking on several controversial cases
encompassing the death penalty the Clean
Water Act and the Humane treatment of
animals in our food supply to name a few
now one of the biggest cases of the Fall
so far is the challenge to Harvard and
the University of North Carolina's use
of race and college admissions a case
that could determine the future of
affirmative action Nationwide judge
Jackson says she'll recuse herself in
that case given her position on
Harvard's Board of overseers ikejachi
ABC News Washington
and this nomination is confirmed history
was made today
the Senate confirming just katanji Brown
Jackson to the Supreme Court on a
bipartisan basis fulfilling President
Biden's promise on the campaign Trail to
nominate the first black woman to the
nation's highest court President Biden
and judge Jackson watching the vote
count from the Roosevelt room vice
president Kamala Harris presiding over
judge Jackson's confirmation vote in the
Senate judge Jackson held one-on-one
meetings with 97 Senators on the hill
she also sat through over 20 hours of
questioning during her hearings and
filed 330 pages of written responses
that's more written questions than any
previous Supreme Court nominee all
Democrats rallied behind judge Jackson
along with three Republicans Joe Jackson
will go down in history as an American
Giant upon whose shoulders others will
stand tall Republicans tried to paint
her as soft on crime Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell once again
slamming Jackson shortly before the vote
claiming she's failing to commit to
oppose expanding the Supreme Court the
solution
is for all the justices
to stay in their Lane there's one right
number of justices who seek to follow
the law
the number is nine ABC news now learning
just Jackson promised Republican senator
Susan Collins